Let's talk about different
types of database relationships.
So there are three different
types of relationships between
entities represented by database
tables. So there's a one
-to-one relationship, there's
a one-to-many relationship,
the one-to-many relationship
is definitely the most
common, and then there are
many-to-many relationships.
Each type represents, so each
different relationship type
represents a different cardinality,
or the number of entity instances
in one table that can be related to
an entity instance in another table.
An entity instance is a row in the
database table, okay? So again,
we can call our tables entities, and
an instance within those is a row.
All right, so let's take a look
over here. So we have a one-to-one
relationship. Now, this is how
these database tables could be
related. So if there was a car company
that only produced one and only
one car model, right, if you
will, then that could be a one-to
-one relationship. If a car model only
belonged to only one car company,
then that would be a one-to
-one relationship. Now, granted,
most car companies may produce many
different car models, but a car
model is still only part of one
car company. but it depends on the
relationship that you're looking
at. In the way that this one is
denoted here, this is saying that
a car company only has one car
model and a car model only has one
car company. So it's important to
know that even though maybe we think
that this should be the way the
relationship is, it depends on how
we have it diagrammed. So this is
why entity relationship diagrams
in databases are really important.
Now, down here, a doctor
has many patients,
okay, but a patient in this diagram
here only has one doctor, okay?
So, a doctor has many patients. A
patient only has one doctor. Now,
let's keep going here. Finally, on
the many-to-many side, a student may
be a part of many courses, right?
You're like, yeah, absolutely. I'm
in many courses and a course has
many students for sure so that's a
many-to-many relationship okay so
these are three different examples
of our three different types of
database relationships so let's look
first at the one-to-many relationship
so this is an example of a one-to
-many relationship my friend and
my company uh so i have a friend
table up here again we call it an
entity and a company table down here.
So my friend table, my company
table. Let's take a look here.
We know that the friend ID is
the primary key of the friend
table and that the company ID is
the primary key of the company
table. So a single friend can
be associated with one and only
one with one with only one company.
Okay. So note that each friend
in the friends table can only
have a single company. So let's
take a look at this, right? So
friend ID number one, Darcy,
right? This is their phone
number here. They're in this
city and their company ID
is one, right? So when I
take a look at this, there's
this company ID number one.
So Darcy is only a part of one company.
However, a single company can
be associated with many friends,
right? Mark and Kim both have
company ID three as their company
ID. So I can see here that Darcy
in this case is working for company
ID number one. Mark and Kim
are both working for company ID
number three. So company ID number
three right is Toys R Us. So
Mark and Kim are both working for
Toys R Us while Darcy is working
for inventorartist.com, okay? So
a single friend can be associated
with only one company, okay?
So they can only work for one
company, but a single company can
be associated with many friends,
okay? So a one-to-many
relationship are implemented by
creating a foreign key in the
many table that references
the primary key value in the
one table. So in this case,
my primary key of company ID is
coming up into my friend table to
create that one-to-many relationship,
okay? A friend is a part
of one company, but a company can
employ many friends, all right?
Okay, here's another example.
Again, this is another
one-to-many relationships
are the most common
type, is an agent, right?
So agent ID 100 right here.
An agent, so Stella Rosellis,
but let's just take a look at my
two tables. So I have an agent table
and an entertainer's table. So
let's take a look at how they are
related. So agent ID 100 right here.
Agent ID 100 exists here as the agent
ID for the country squires and
the Mike Hernandez trio okay so in
this case I have an agent can work for
many entertainers but an entertainer
only has one agent so again this
is a one-to-many relationship now
another example or another relationship
type is a one-to-one relationship
so this right here is an example
my employees table and my
compensation table this is an example
of a one-to-one relationship a single
employee can be associated with
only one compensation record. Okay,
so note that each foreign key
value for employee ID appears
only once in the compensation
table, and a single
compensation record can be
associated with only one employee. So
this is just saying here, it's
a one-to-one relationship.
One employee has one compensation
record, one compensation
record has one employee
associated with it. These
are less common but still
utilized in the relationships
between two different tables
in a relational database.
All right, then we have our many
-to-many relationship. This is
an example of students and
classes, okay? So I have a student
table and I have a classes table.
So here I have a single student
can be associated with many
classes, right? So a student can
take many classes and a single
class can be associated with
many students so a class can have
many students in it. So this is
a many to many relationship but
how is this implemented in a
relational database? So you might
be thinking oh well up here I
could have you know let's
say class ID class ID
right here and this class
ID you know, I could
say this student was a
part of class 9-0-0-0-1,
okay?
However, though,
then I would have to have another
column of class ID and another class
listed, 9-0-0-0-2, right? If I wanted
to have all of the classes, class
ID 1, class ID 2, class ID 3,
class ID 4, that this student ever
takes, so then I have all these columns
of classes that this student has
taken but yeah I don't know what
grade they got in the class so that's
not I don't that's not going to
work I also I'm going to have all
these extra columns and yeah it's
just not going to work right I don't
even know what class but I don't
even know what grade they ended up
getting in the class I'm also then at
that point I have a student info but
then I know that a table should only
be about one thing so then I have
a student info table but then I
have all these class IDs is listed.
So at that point, is it really still a
student table? So I'm
not going to do that.
I'm also not going to have a class ID
down here and have a student ID table,
or sorry, a student ID column, and
have one student ID listed here
of 6-0-0-0-1 and say, oh Zachary
took this class and another student
ID here of 6-0-0-0-2 and then I'm
going to have all these columns
of different student IDs that
have taken this one class but yet
what if advanced music theory
has had it significantly more or
less students then I'm going to have
a lot of empty spaces so I can't
do that either right and I also
still don't know what grade they
got in the class Like it's,
something here isn't matching up. So
how do I make these? I can't bring
student ID down here and I can't
bring class ID up here. So what
do I do to figure out this many
-to-many relationship? And the answer
is that many-to-many relationships
are implemented by using a
third bridge or a linking table,
okay? So call these
bridge tables or linking
tables. The bridge table,
or call the linking table,
at minimum has two foreign keys
that reference the primary keys of
each of the other tables, okay?
So each of the other two tables is
related to the bridge table with a
one-to-many relationship such that
each primary key value can appear
multiple times in the bridge table
as a foreign key. So let's take a
look at this. So when I take a look
at this, I have my classes table
and my students table. Now this is
just fun. This is just fun. So let's
break this down. and if you don't
understand please please reach out
with questions okay but as you work
with databases it's become a lot
more clear so give yourself time
if you're like oh I'm having a hard
time understanding this give yourself
some time and then let's reach out
with questions as well so I have
my students table my classes table
I know I can't put student id in
my classes table I know I can't
put classes in my students table so
what I'm going to do instead is I'm
going to create the student schedule
table and what this is going to do
is it's going to take the primary
key from the students table and
the primary key from the classes
table and it's going to list both of
them. These two together, this isn't
something we need to know
specifically for this class, but these
two together become a composite
primary key. Basically these both of
these two columns together become
my primary key. So that I can have
student ID 6-0-0-0-0-3, right? It's
repeating twice here in my student
schedule table. And the reason is,
is because this student is in the
intro to political science class and
is involved in the American history
class, right? so I can have student
id 6003 say that's Reagan I can
have Reagan in this class and in
this class right no big deal I can
also then at this point what other
information do you think I know if
I know what student and what class
they are in they are in and let's
say they were in and I know maybe
then what grade they received, right?
So this person got an A, this
person got an A, this person got an
A-, this person, whatever it may
be. So I can say, right, that this
student in this class now got maybe
this grade. So now this student
schedule table allows me to have a one
-to-many relationship with my students
table and my classes table and
allows me to track other information
about the student experience here
in my relational database, okay?
So that's how I deal with many-to
-many relationships is I make them
into a one-to-many relationship,
right? So now a classes, right?
Classes can have many
classes listed in the student
schedule table and a student
can be a part of many
classes in my student schedule
table, okay? All right.
So a database schema, again, this
is my entity relationship diagram.
So in this example here, I have
an author, and an author can
be an author of many books, but
a book only has, in this case,
one author.
So that many side is
receiving that foreign
key. The many side
receives a foreign key.
When I look back at my
dog park database, let's
look at this one. What type
of relationship is this?
I hope you said, Reagan, it's a
one-to-many relationship, right?
My dog owner can have many dogs,
but my dog can only have one owner.
Okay, perfect.
Okay.
Now, let's get into the database
you're going to be working with
a lot in this class. And this
is the Overland Peak Database.
This is one of the oldest, largest,
and most successful ski resorts
in Pennsylvania. Now, I wish this
was a real ski resort. However,
it's not. It's modeled after a
potential ski resort. But no,
I wish this was a real ski resort,
but it is modeled after one.
So we are going to be working with
this Overland Peak Resort and just
think of it as being a super
successful ski resort in Pennsylvania.
All right. So the Overland Entity
Relationship Diagram, it looks like
this. so maybe you're getting a little
overwhelmed don't be overwhelmed
we've got this we're going to step
everything through step by step
so here i have let's count how many
different entities and again we
call them tables so i have one two
three four five six seven i have
seven different tables going on in
my overland database i have seven
different tables that exist now
let's look at the relationship pop
quiz here is my employee table related
to any other tables in my overland
ski resort no okay it does not have
any relationships right there's
no lines drawing it to any of the
other tables so no it doesn't all
right so that's something to note
however i do have other relationships
going on here so let's look at an
example so in my household table
i am tracking households. So I
skied a ton growing up and we, you
know, there was in my household,
my dad and my brother skied and me.
So we were all a part of the same
household and that household had,
in our case, three guests, right?
So a household can have many guests,
but a guest is only a part of one
household. Okay. So again, because
the guest is on the mini side,
it's going to receive the foreign
key, which is household ID. So my
household ID is coming from my, as
the primary key in my household
table to the foreign key in my guest
table. All right. Perfect. So that's
how that relationship is working.
We can see here that in my day
table, the date ID is coming from
the date ID is coming from the
day table as the primary key into
my visit table as day ID. So it's
named just a little bit differently.
That's okay. We're going to
have to get used to those types
of things. And that's why we'll
rely a lot on a data dictionary.
These provide the names of all
tables and all fields in each table.
So they provide additional information
about each field. So primary
key, foreign key, what type of
data goes into the field, what
does it stand for, things like
that. So if I look here at this data
dictionary for my dog park database,
I can see down here that in
my dog table, right, I have the owner
ID and the foreign key references
the dog owner table. So when I
look at this, I know, oh yeah,
owner ID is the foreign key in my
dog table and it references my dog
owner table. So I can tell here, I
have a little bit more description
on the structure of my database
using a data dictionary.
So I have my two tables listed
out here. I have my different
field names. I have whether
or not they are a key, the
data type, whether or not
they can be null, meaning an
empty value. We'll talk more
about that in a description.
So looking here at my Overland
data dictionary, I can
see here that I have a day
table and I have a guest
table. In my guest table, I
have a different field names
listed. I have guest ID,
which I know is a primary key,
uniquely identifies each guest
at Overland Ski Resort. And my
household ID is a foreign key
that references the household
table. Okay. So just keep that
in mind. I, along with my entity
relationship diagram that kind
of visually shows me how the
different tables relate. I also
have my data dictionary, which
describes to me for each given
table? What are the different
records in that table? What do
they mean? Those types of things,
okay?
So, so what? Assuming we are
not database administrators yet,
right? Some of you may be. Why
should we care about the structure of
relational databases? Why do we
care how these tables relate to
one another? These allow us to be
more effective consumers of data
by extracting the right data to
serve a business need. In other
words, we can query the database
to understand important business
questions okay now why so when
we say we can query the database
to answer important business
questions we can query the
database what does that mean
that means we are going to learn
structured query language okay
structured query language sql is
also what people call it you
might hear it called sql or
sql i generally say sql but some
people say SQL, that's okay.
SQL queries is an inquiry into the
database to extract desired data.
So we are going to query a database
and pull the data out of it.
So examples, I can say, hey, I'm
going to write an SQL query, so
there's going to be some certain
code we're going to use. I'm going
to say, show me all the stores that
had at least 5 million in sales
last year. Show me the total number
of cells closed by each salesperson.
So I'm going to query all this
data held in my relational
databases. I'm going to query it.
I'm going to pull data out of it by
looking at and writing an SQL
query. So structured query language.
Why you should learn SQL even
if you're not a developer.
These days almost everyone has
to work with data in some form
or another. Usually it's through
spreadsheets or databases, but
if you can learn a little SQL, you
can become so much more powerful
in your job. Here is the basic
SQL select statement syntax.
And what this does is this is the
basics of how we are going to say,
show me all the data from a certain
table that meets this criteria,
order it in this way. We're
gonna dive into this. It's gonna
be fun. Are you ready for SQL?
Let's go. Thanks everybody.